so in stoicism philosophy is often
divided into three main categories or
parts logic physics and ethics it is the
ethical teachings of stoicism that have
become particularly famous today but the
other parts are also equally important
to understand in order to get a sort of
full picture of this school to many
logic is the basis from which all
philosophy must start it's a sort of
jumping off point for all other aspects
of philosophy right um today logic might
seem to many people like an obvious
thing things are logical because they're
logical right but in philosophy logic is
actually a kind of science it's a it's a
way of studying examining the nature of
truth and how we can know what is truth